Đâu năm 1 in chính trọng 4 milan, cao cao khá nhật đang xúc số khi thế,
nạn đói giận dạng nếu chọng ở khách tình được bằng bác bộ.
Đàn kịp tới đưa ra khẩu hiệu và con thóc của nhật để xa quyết nạn đó.
Khẩu hiệu hợp lòng dân đó đã thuổi buông mọi lượng cách mà,
được hàng chêu quân trúng vàng cao trọng về nguyễn đổ chính quyền thật sĩnh và thay sài.
Còn tốt nhật tại định là nọc, này là định quan nhân khiến của hả nội,
cách đây tạm mi năm trong khi thế lòng trời lợi đất ở quyết 2 hào,
một thách nhiên trải, còn thách nhiên chú quốc thành khoang dầu đã thang ra cùng của chúng phải nhân dân và lực lượng biệt mình,
lánh phá, cứ có thóc để chia trò dân nhau.
Hồi hợp, hơi khách cùng sống người đồ với định lạng hút đó là kỳ đẹp không thể hảo quên trong cuộc đời.